the thirteen-year-old who turned into
Janis Joplin on a GT Tiffany Haddish
reveals the identity of Beyonce's biter
plus the NPR raccoon is safe guys
everybody I'm Denny direct oh this is
the daily Denny and today Wednesday June
13th the day a raccoon became an
Internet superstar more on that in just
a few but first we've got to talk about
another young star in the making
thirteen year old Courtney had wings I
mean this girl was plagued with social
anxiety before her America's Got Talent
audition I mean just look how shy she
was what's your name Courtney and how
are you 13 13 what's your favorite
subject in school music what kind of
music - no okay so clearly little 13
year old Courtney a bit starstruck a
whole lot nervous right well you won't
believe what happened next I'm still
sure watch this
[Applause]
oh my god indeed I've watched that five
times already this little girl was
possessed by the spirit of Janis Joplin
hit the stage and completely floored the
judges with her trippy performance a
star is born ladies and gents and guess
what she is going straight to the live
shows the only thing I can do for you
young lady is give you
[Applause]
last night Courtney tweeted the golden
buzzer was more than she ever could have
dreamed of but you earned it girl and I
got to say so far the golden buzzers on
a GT have been on point and something
tells me we won't forget about them for
a long time Courtney was so memorable
but what did you guys think of her
performance
were you guys shot by her as I was give
me up all right well as Courtney
continues on her journey to becoming
America's champ The Hollywood Reporter
has crowned Tiffany Haddish comedies new
queen she's holding court on their
latest cover but it's inside the mag
where Tiffany is as unfiltered as ever
revealing this knotty encounter with
Leonardo DiCaprio
she says she met him at a party two or
three months ago where she made a
serious pass at him quote I asked him if
he'd let me hit that
he's like tiffany is so funny I'm like
I'm serious and then he goes I may not
do it
apparently Tiffany's only stipulation
was she wants to do it with him as his
character from What's Eating Gilbert
Grape because quote that performance
deserves a real reward uh-huh and that's
not the only T she's spilling nope
Tiffany finally reveals the identity of
the actress who she claims fit fiance
quick recap Tiffany told GQ than an
actress bit Beyonce in the face at a
party and that Beyonce stopped her from
getting in a fight with the woman now
she didn't name name names but two
sources at the time told et it was
actress Sanaa Lathan who playfully bit
Beyonce when The Hollywood Reporter
asked if it was indeed Sanaa she smiled
and said quote I'm super good friends
with her stepmom and her dad and they
were mad at me they were like why would
you do this to the family but I didn't
try to ruin her career I never said her
name I was just trying to say how
Beyonce kept me from going to jail that
night I could have just shut my whole
career down I want to know what happened
to those NDA's tiffany claims she had a
sign from Beyonce's team alright well I
think it's safe to say this case is
closed or at least I'm done talking
about it here I just needed to close the
loop and now I can finally have a good
night's sleep so Thank You Tiffany
speaking of we can now all rest easy
knowing that the raccoon s scaled a
skyscraper in Minnesota is safe that's
right a critter found himself stuck on
the UV
building in st. Paul Minnesota and
decided the only way to go was up the
raccoons riveting adventure up 23
stories was captured by MPR's
Tim Nelson who spotted the raccoons
stranded on a ledge of the building
before it started its climb the raccoon
literally scaled up the building and
here it is at the 23rd floor thankfully
the little guy finally made it up the
roof and was trapped by a wildlife
management services with cat food and
will be released to the wild
needless to say hashtag MPR raccoon has
been trending all day and the harrowing
journey has made national headlines
he couldn't ignore it here on the daily
Denny and that was your exclusive sneak
peek at rockets adventures in adventures
for all right that's enough fun for
today
are you following daily Denny on
Facebook do you have the daily Denney
playlist saved on youtube if not do it
and then come back tomorrow cool cool
[Music]